This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the 1997 drama, Life is Beautiful, Roberto Benini plays an Italian bookshop owner. He is Jewish and during the Holocaust, the Nazis deport him and his small son to a concentration camp. Achtung, Achtung! The Austrians have been killed for a few days. Surrounded by squalor and fear. The father has a choice. He can tell his young son the truth that they have been captured by evil people and are likely facing death. Or he can make up a fantastic story
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。在1997年的电影《美丽人生》中，罗伯托·贝尼尼饰演了一位开书店的意大利人。他是犹太人，在大屠杀期间，纳粹将他和他的小儿子 deport（驱逐）到了集中营。注意力，注意！奥地利人已经被杀了几天了。周围是一片肮脏和恐惧。这位父亲面临着一个选择。他可以告诉年幼的儿子真相，即他们被坏人抓住了，很可能面临死亡。或者他可以编造一个奇妙的故事
to cover up the horrors of the concentration camp. As the guards bark instructions in German and go over the punishments that await the prisoners, the former bookshop owner explains to his son that they are only playing an elaborate game. It's designed to put players through a series of difficult challenges, painful little food, cramped quarters, even violence. The goal is to survive these challenges, ideally without crying or making a fuss. The winner gets a prize that sounds amazing to the little boy. He gets to ride a tank. Life is beautiful when town to win a raft of awards, including a best actor Oscar for Roberto Benini. Millions laughed and wept as they heard the story of the brave father who reinvented reality to help his son survive the Holocaust.
来掩盖集中营的恐怖。当卫兵用德语大声下达指令，并细数等待着囚犯的惩罚时，这位前书店老板向儿子解释，他们其实只是在玩一个精心设计的游戏。这个游戏的目的是让玩家经历一系列艰难的挑战、痛苦、少得可怜的食物、拥挤的住所，甚至是暴力。目标是在这些挑战中生存下来，最好不要哭泣或大惊小怪。获胜者将获得一件对小男孩来说听起来极其诱人的奖品。他将赢得驾驶一辆坦克的奖励。当赢得了一系列奖项时，生活是美好的，其中包括罗伯托·贝尼尼的最佳男主角奥斯卡奖。数百万人在听到这个勇敢的父亲重塑现实以帮助他的儿子在大屠杀中生存的故事时，都笑了也哭了。
Today on Hidden Brain, we continue our exploration of when and how much our perceptions of reality shape how we think and what we feel. This is part two of our story. If you haven't heard the first episode, I strongly recommend you go back and start there. In that episode, we saw how mindsets affect our minds. Today, the effect that mindsets have on our bodies. One of Alia Kram's earliest introductions to mindsets came not from psychology, but from medicine. For centuries now, medical professionals have observed that when patients get help from a
今天在《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们将继续探讨我们的现实感知何时以及在多大程度上塑造了我们的思维和感受。这是我们故事的第二部分。如果你还没有听过第一集，我强烈建议你回去从那里开始。在那一集中，我们看到了思维模式如何影响我们的思想。今天，我们将探讨思维模式对我们身体的影响。阿莉亚·克拉姆接触思维模式的最早经历之一不是来自心理学，而是来自医学。几个世纪以来，医学专业人士观察到，当患者得到
dedicated and trusted doctor, it isn't just the doctor's cures that make patients better. The expectations that patients have, that trust in their physicians, and the rituals embedded in the art of medicine, all play a role in outcomes. At Stanford University, Alia today studies the effects that our mindsets have on us, but she says many of her findings can be traced back to that insight from medicine. Our work was very much inspired by research in medicine on the placebo effect. And now, in medicine, you think about the placebo effect as just this magical or mysterious response to a sham pill or fake procedure. But if you think about it, what's actually going on there is a physical change in response
敬业且值得信赖的医生的帮助时，让患者康复的不仅仅是医生的治疗方案。患者对医生的期望、对医生的信任，以及医学艺术中内嵌的仪式感，都在治疗结果中发挥了作用。在斯坦福大学，阿莉亚如今研究的是我们的思维模式对我们产生的影响，但她说她的许多发现都可以追溯到医学领域的那个洞察。我们的工作在很大程度上受到了医学领域关于安慰剂效应的研究的启发。现在，在医学中，你可能会认为安慰剂效应只是对假药或虚假程序的某种神奇或神秘的反应。但如果你仔细想想，那里实际发生的是身体对
to the pure belief that you are going to heal or feel less pain or feel less anxiety or have better sleep. And we have lots of data on placebo effects because they're, you know, viewed as being so relevant that we need to control for them in every single pharmaceutical trial. The placebo effect is so well recognized in medicine that when someone invents a new drug, the Food and Drug Administration says it isn't enough to give the drug to patients and show they got better. They may have gotten better because they thought they would get better, the placebo effect. So companies testing drugs have to give it to two groups of people, both of whom think they are getting the drug.
坚信自己将会痊愈、减轻疼痛、减少焦虑或改善睡眠的一种生理变化。我们有大量关于安慰剂效应的数据，因为它们，你知道的，被认为非常相关，以至于我们在每一个药物试验中都需要对它们进行控制。安慰剂效应在医学界得到了广泛的认可，以至于当有人发明了一种新药时，美国食品药品监督管理局表示，仅仅把这种药给患者并证明他们病情好转是不够的。他们的病情好转可能是因为他们认为自己会好转，这就是安慰剂效应。因此，测试药物的公司必须将药物分发给两组人，这两组人都认为自己正在服用这种药物。
Only one gets the royal medication, the other gets a placebo, a pill that has no chemical effects on the body. Presumably, both groups are influenced by the placebo effect. So if patients in the drug arm of the study do better than patients in the placebo arm, we say the drug works. Of course, the more accurate way to describe this would be to say the drug has effects that go above and beyond the placebo effect. Across many different fields of medicine, scientists often find that promising drugs fail
只有一组服用真正的药物，另一组服用安慰剂，这是一种对身体没有化学作用的药丸。可以推测，两组人都受到了安慰剂效应的影响。因此，如果研究中用药组的患者表现得比安慰剂组的患者更好，我们就会说这种药管用。当然，更准确的描述方式应该是说这种药具有超越安慰剂效应的效果。在许多不同的医学领域中，科学家们经常发现有前景的药物
to do better than the placebo effect. The same number of patients recover when they are given sham medications compared to when they are given actual medications. So our work has tried to move beyond the placebo effect to try to think about, okay, if our beliefs about treatment matter, right, if the belief that this treatment is going to work or this treatment is going to be harmful, have an effect on our reality, what other mindsets might be at play in medicine? One of those mindsets has to do with how we think about side effects.
并没有比安慰剂效应表现得更好。给予假药的患者与给予实际药物的患者康复人数相同。因此，我们的工作一直试图超越安慰剂效应，去思考，好吧，如果我们对治疗的看法很重要，对吧，如果我们相信这种治疗会起作用或者这种治疗会有害的信念对我们的现实产生了影响，那么医学中还可能存在哪些其他的思维模式呢？其中一种思维模式与我们如何看待副作用有关。
What we've also learned is that you can have mindsets about the meaning of side effects in the context of a treatment. And this becomes really important, right? Because whenever you get a new drug or therapy, you're told, well, here are all the side effects that's gonna go along with that. And what often happens is that when people experience those side effects,
我们还了解到，在治疗的背景下，你可以对副作用的含义持有某种思维模式。这变得非常重要，对吧？因为无论什么时候你接受一种新药或疗法，你都会被告知，好吧，以下是伴随而来的所有副作用。而经常发生的情况是，当人们体验到这些副作用时，
they feel like concerned, right? They feel like, oh, maybe this is harmful or maybe the treatment is not working or maybe my condition is particularly severe resistant to treatment. And what we realize is that in some cases there's a totally different mindset about the meaning of side effects that you could have. For example, when you take a vaccination, the experience of side effects like fever or fatigue or pain at the injection site are actually signs that the vaccine is working, that it is boosting your immune system to learn what it would be like if it were to encounter this virus. And therefore those symptoms are not negative signs of harm. There, in fact, signs that the treatment is working and your body is getting stronger.
他们会感到担忧，对吧？他们会觉得，哦，也许这有害，或者也许治疗没有起作用，或者也许我的病情特别严重且对治疗有抗药性。我们意识到，在某些情况下，对于副作用的含义，你可以拥有一种完全不同的思维模式。例如，当你接种疫苗时，经历发烧、疲劳或注射部位疼痛等副作用，其实是疫苗正在起作用的信号，这表明它正在增强你的免疫力，让你了解如果将来遇到这种病毒会是什么样的情景。因此，这些症状并不是有害的消极信号。事实上，它们是治疗正在起作用、你的身体正在变强的信号。
One of your studies looked at peanut allergies and found that the treatment mindset could change the way patients were thinking about their allergies. Tell me about that work area. Yeah, so food allergies are a major problem in the US and it's growing, right? So I imagine a lot of your listeners have children or no children with food allergies, allergies to peanuts or other nuts, milk, egg, and so forth. And they're very debilitating, right? You are constantly worried that you're going to be having exposure to the thing that your child's allergic to, and therefore you need to go to great lengths to avoid those things. And the presence of that allergen can cause major reactions and anaphylaxis and in some cases even death. So these allergies cause a lot of anxiety.
你的其中一项研究着眼于花生过敏，并发现治疗的思维模式可以改变患者思考其过敏症的方式。能跟我讲讲那项工作吗？是的，食物过敏在美国是个大问题，而且还在不断增长，对吧？所以我想你的很多听众都有孩子，或者认识有食物过敏的儿童，比如对花生或其他坚果、牛奶、鸡蛋等等过敏。这些过敏非常折磨人，对吧？你总是担心自己会接触到你孩子过敏的东西，因此你需要付出巨大的努力去避免这些东西。而这种过敏原的存在可能会引起重大的反应、过敏性休克，在某些情况下甚至会导致死亡。所以这些过敏引发了大量的焦虑。
Fortunately, there are great treatments for them that are being developed. Carinneido here at Stanford has done a number of clinical trials showing that oral immunotherapy can be highly effective for getting children to become tolerant to their former allergen. And oral immunotherapy is essentially the process of taking small but gradually increasing doses of the thing you're allergic to. Teeny, teeny, teeny tiny doses of peanut protein,
幸运的是，目前正在开发针对它们的极好的治疗方法。斯坦福大学的卡里·内多在这里做了一系列临床试验，表明口服免疫疗法在让儿童对他们以前的过敏原产生耐受性方面非常有效。口服免疫疗法本质上是这样的过程：服用少量但逐渐增加剂量的你过敏的东西。微乎其微的花生蛋白质剂量，
for example, that gradually increase over six or seven months to the point where then these kids are able to tolerate peanuts. So I was having a conversation with Kari and she confided in us that they were having a lot of issues, either getting people into the trials or, you know, having them drop out, in part because the kids were experiencing side effects. And it made sense. They were taking the things that they were allergic to and they were having these reactions. But what she shared with us was that they were afraid of these reactions, but they need not be. Because of this
例如，在六到七个月内逐渐增加，直到这些孩子能够耐受花生。所以我和卡里谈过，她向我们吐露，他们在招募人们参加试验，或者让他们坚持到底方面遇到了很多问题，部分原因是孩子们正在经历副作用。这是可以理解的。他们正在服用他们过敏的东西，并且正在产生这些反应。但她与我们分享的是，他们害怕这些反应，但其实不必如此。因为通过这种
controlled method, they were being exposed to them in a way that their bodies were actually learning how to tolerate peanut or the allergen. It was like, you know, if you go to the gym to work out, you might feel some pain or discomfort, you might feel soreness a day or two after, but that was part of the process. That's how you grow your muscle stronger. If you don't get sore, you're probably not getting stronger. And so that was a real aha, and we thought, this is our realm, right?
受控的方法，他们接触这些物质的方式实际上让他们的身体学会了如何耐受花生或其他过敏原。这就好比，你知道的，如果你去健身房锻炼，你可能会感到一些疼痛或不适，一两天后你可能会感到酸痛，但这只是过程的一部分。这就是你如何让肌肉变得更强壮的方法。如果你没有感到酸痛，你可能就没有变强。所以那是一个真正的灵光一闪的时刻，我们想，这是我们的领域，对吧？
This is psychology. So we thought, what could we do to kind of piggyback on to this treatment, to design an intervention that would help improve the experience and potentially even outcomes of these children going through this treatment. So what we did was we took 50 children adolescents and their parents going through the treatment. So they were all getting the same exact treatment. It was this seven month oral immunotherapy, gradually increases of peanuts. And what we did was we randomized half of them into a treatment as usual conditions. So they were told, you might have side effects. These are the things you need to worry about and seek out extra care. These are the things that are fine
这是心理学。所以我们想，我们可以做些什么来顺应这种治疗，设计一种干预措施，帮助改善经历这种治疗的儿童的体验，甚至可能改善他们的治疗结果。所以我们做的是，我们招募了50名正在接受治疗的儿童、青少年及其父母。所以他们都在接受完全相同的治疗。这是为期七个月的口服免疫疗法，逐渐增加花生的剂量。我们做的是，我们将其中一半随机分配到常规治疗条件中。所以他们被告知，你可能会有副作用。这些是你需要担心并寻求额外护理的事情。这些是没问题的
But then we randomized half into our intervention condition and that was a condition in which we informed them that these side effects were signs That the treatment was doing its job that their bodies were getting stronger and that they were becoming tolerant to peanuts. So we created that mindset through verbal information that the providers and the healthcare teams shared with their patients. We also changed what we put on the pamphlets that were given to the kids. We had the kids do some exercises where they thought they wrote a letter to themself three months from now saying, what should you tell yourself when you experience
但接着我们将另一半随机分到我们的干预条件中，在那个条件下，我们告知他们这些副作用是治疗在发挥作用的信号，表明他们的身体正在变得强壮，并且他们正在对花生产生耐受。因此，我们通过医护人员和医疗团队与患者分享的语言信息创造了那种思维模式。我们还更改了发给孩子们的宣传册上的内容。我们让孩子们做了一些练习，让他们思考并写一封信给三个月后的自己，上面写着：当你经历
a symptom and they were to write things like it's a positive sign and so forth. So we did a lot of things to create this mindset. What we found was that the kids with the symptoms are positive signals mindset is that those kids had far less anxiety throughout the treatment. Their parents had far less anxiety throughout the treatment, which if you're a parent with a kid with allergies, you know that this matters. So that was interesting, but we also found that they had fewer symptoms, not early on, when the doses were small, but as they were leaving towards the end of treatment,
某种症状时，你应该对自己说些什么，他们会写下诸如“这是一个积极的信号”之类的话。所以我们做了很多事情来建立这种思维模式。我们发现，那些拥有“症状是积极信号”这种思维模式的孩子，在整个治疗过程中焦虑感要少得多。他们的父母在整个治疗过程中的焦虑感也少得多，如果你是一个有患过敏症孩子的父母，你知道这有多重要。所以这很有趣，但我们也发现他们的症状减少了，不是在早期剂量还小的时候，而是在他们接近治疗尾声时，
when they were supposed to be done with treatment and tolerant to peanuts, they had fewer symptoms at that point in time. And most interesting of all, we found that the treatment was in fact more effective for them, at least as measured by IgG-4 levels, which is a biological marker, an immune marker of allergic tolerance. So this change in mindset, again, here it's same exact treatment, objectively doing the same exact thing. The only thing that changed were their mindsets about the meaning of symptoms, and that mindset made all the difference. It made it the treatment more enjoyable, more tolerable, and ultimately more effective.
当他们本应完成治疗并对花生耐受时，他们在那个时间点上的症状更少了。最有趣的是，我们发现这种治疗对他们来说确实更有效，至少从IgG-4水平的测量来看是这样，这是一种生物标志物，是过敏耐受性的免疫标志物。因此，这种思维模式的改变，在这里再次强调，是完全相同的治疗，客观上做着完全相同的事情。唯一改变的是他们对症状含义的思维模式，而这种思维模式带来了所有的不同。它让治疗变得更愉快、更能忍受，并最终更加有效。
How much of the mechanism do you think is actually about the nature of anxiety, which is that it's one thing to be stressed, and it's another thing to be anxious about being stressed. And in some ways, I think what the mindset is doing here is it's relieving some of the anxiety. So you still have the difficulty of the treatment for peanut allergies, the fundamental challenges are not changing, but your own anxieties about those challenges are changing. How much of a role do you think that's playing in the outcomes we're seeing earlier? You know, I think it is playing a substantial role, but I don't think it's making all the difference, right? So it's not just, and we tested this, you
你认为机制中有多少实际上与焦虑的本质有关，也就是说，感到压力是一回事，而对感到压力感到焦虑则是另一回事。在某些情况下，我认为这种思维模式在这里所做的是它缓解了一些焦虑。所以你仍然要面对花生过敏治疗的困难，根本的挑战没有改变，但你对这些挑战自身的焦虑正在改变。你认为这在我们之前看到的治疗结果中起到了多大的作用？你知道的，我认为它发挥了重要作用，但我并不认为它带来了全部的不同，对吧？所以它不仅仅是，而且我们对此进行了测试，你
look at mediation models or models in which you ask does the change in anxiety explain the changes in the IGG-4 levels, and it might explain some of it, but it's never all of it. And so what I think is going on here is, again, the effects of mindset are manifold, they're multiple. As we talked about, it changes in attention. And as you've mentioned here, it's changes in affect or emotion. In this case, maybe reductions in anxiety. But it also changes in your motivation, right? So you're more motivated or activated
看中介模型或询问“焦虑的变化是否能解释IgG-4水平的变化”的模型，它可能解释了一部分，但绝对不是全部。所以我认为这里发生的事情是，再次强调，思维模式的影响是多方面的、多重的。正如我们所讨论的，它是注意力的改变。正如你在这里提到的，它是情感或情绪的改变。在这种情况下，可能是焦虑的减少。但它也改变了你的动机，对吧？所以你更有动力或更积极地
to do healthier things. So they might have actually been more healthy in their life, engaged in healthier behaviors. We didn't measure that, but I wouldn't be surprised if that were the case. And then lastly, it confers changes in your physiology. So based on these prediction processing models, if you think your body is strong, that you're going to be healthy, that you're going to be okay when you're exposed to peanuts. That sends a whole different message to your body about what it needs to freak out about, you know, or prioritize.
去做更健康的事情。所以他们实际上可能在生活中更健康，参与了更健康的行为了。我们没有测量这一点，但如果真是这样，我一点也不会感到意外。最后，它赋予了你的生理机能变化。基于这些预测处理模型，如果你认为自己的身体很强壮，你会很健康，你在接触花生时会没事的。这会向你的身体发送一个完全不同的信息，关于它需要为什么事情大惊小怪（你知道的），或者优先处理什么。
And so to be honest with you, we're really just diving down into that question now of like, how exactly does that mindset lead to changes in physiology? And yes, one mechanism is anxiety and emotion, but we also think there's more cognitive prediction relevant mechanisms that connect those predictions how the mind affects the body. When we are nervous, we might feel our hands trembling. Angry thoughts can change blood flow to our arms and legs and face. Excitement can make our hearts pound and our breath quicker. When we come back, more evidence that what happens in the mind doesn't stay in the mind. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
所以老实说，我们现在才真正深入探讨那个问题，比如：这种思维模式究竟是如何导致生理变化的？是的，一个机制是焦虑和情绪，但我们也认为还有更多与认知预测相关的机制，将这些预测与思维如何影响身体连接起来。当我们紧张时，我们可能会感到双手颤抖。愤怒的想法可以改变流向我们手臂、腿和脸部的血流。兴奋可以使我们的心跳加速，呼吸急促。当我们回来时，会有更多的证据表明，脑海中发生的事情并不仅仅停留在脑海中。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。
In Hadees as a college athlete, Alia Crum spent years feeling like she never got enough exercise and also worrying that she was overeating or not eating the right foods. No matter how hard she worked to get ready for athletic competition, Alia felt like she was not doing enough. It was an enormous source of unhappiness and dissatisfaction in her life. More recently, like millions of other Americans, the Stanford Psychologist sent out for some genetic tests. She wanted to know more about two genes that predispose people to not exercising enough and overeating.
作为一名大学运动员，阿莉亚·克拉姆在哈迪斯度过了多年，她总是觉得自己运动量不够，同时也担心自己吃得太多或没有吃对食物。无论她为竞技体育做了多么刻苦的准备，阿莉亚都觉得自己做得还不够。这是她生活中不快乐和不满的巨大来源。最近，和其他数百万美国人一样，这位斯坦福心理学家做了一些基因检测。她想更多地了解两个导致人们运动不足和暴饮暴食倾向的基因。
One is the CREB-1 gene and one is the FTO gene. And the FTO gene was thought to increase your risk for obesity because if you have the risk allele of this gene, you would generally feel less full after you eat. And if you feel less full after you eat, you can imagine you eat more. So fourth, gain weight over time. Therefore, increases your risk for obesity. The CREB-1 gene was thought to increase risk for obesity through changing our physiological response to exercise.
一个是CREB-1基因，另一个是FTO基因。人们认为FTO基因会增加患肥胖症的风险，因为如果你拥有这个基因的风险等位基因，你在进食后通常会感觉不那么饱。如果你在进食后感觉不那么饱，你可以想象你会吃得更多。以此类推，随着时间的推移体重增加。因此，增加了你患肥胖症的风险。人们认为CREB-1基因通过改变我们对运动的生理反应来增加患肥胖症的风险。
So people who have the risk allele of the CREB-1 gene basically feel hotter, are less efficient cardiovascularly when they exercise. Basically exercise is harder, and therefore you're less likely to do it. Over time you might gain weight and become more at risk for obesity. When Alia got back her test results, she found she had the protective version of one gene and the riskier version of the other. I actually had the protective allele for the exercise gene which made a lot of sense to me. And I also found that I had the risk allele for the food related gene, which immediately made a lot of sense to me.
因此，拥有CREB-1基因风险等位基因的人在运动时基本上会感觉更热，心血管效率更低。基本上运动更困难，因此你进行运动的可能性就更小。随着时间的推移，你可能会体重增加，患肥胖症的风险会更高。当阿莉亚拿到检测结果时，她发现其中一个基因她拥有保护性版本，而另一个基因她拥有风险更高的版本。我实际上拥有运动基因的保护性等位基因，这对我来说非常合理。我还发现我拥有与食物相关的基因的风险等位基因，这让我立刻觉得非常合理。
I started thinking back to all those times that I would eat and eat and eat and not feel full. Alia thought back to her college days. She remembered how she would exercise and exercise and then exercise some more. Well, that now made total sense. She had a genetic variant that predisposed her to find exercise relatively easy and enjoyable. The gene that predisposed her to overeating? Well that made perfect sense too. Alia felt she now had an explanation for her own behavior.
我开始回想所有那些我会一直吃、一直吃、一直吃却感觉不到饱的时间。阿莉亚回想起她的大学时代。她记得自己是如何锻炼、锻炼、再锻炼的。好吧，这现在完全说得通了。她拥有一个基因变异，使她倾向于认为运动相对容易且令人愉快。那个让她倾向于暴饮暴食的基因呢？好吧，这也完全说得通。阿莉亚觉得自己现在对自己的行为有了解释。
Then she stopped herself. She was a Mindsets researcher. With the genetic tests actually telling her important information, or with a simply a way for her to engage in storytelling, to allow her Mindsets to find confirmation for her pre-existing beliefs. When you get this information, you immediately make up a story that helps explain it, right, you know, like I did.
然后她停了下来。她是一名思维模式研究人员。基因测试真的在告诉她重要信息吗？还是这只是一种让她参与讲故事的方式，好让她的思维模式为她先入为主的信念找到证实？当你得到这个信息时，你立刻编造了一个有助于解释它的故事，对吧，你知道的，就像我做的那样。
It was like, okay, that makes sense. But then I also, you know, as we've talked about it, it changed my attention. I retrieved experiences that confirmed this genetic profile. I also, as I got this information, then I started noticing when I was eating that confirmed this genetic profile. I also, as I got this information, then I started noticing when I was eating. Oh, I'm because I'm at risk for this FTO gene,
这就像是，好吧，这说得通。但随后我也，你知道的，正如我们所讨论的，它改变了我的注意力。我回忆起了证实这个基因特征的经历。同样，当我得到这个信息时，我开始注意到我吃东西的时候证实了这个基因特征。同样，当我有这个信息时，我开始注意到我吃东西的时候。哦，因为我有这个FTO基因的风险，
I'm probably not gonna feel so full. And then I would notice myself not feeling so full, right? So you can start to see, and I noticed myself, how this information was influencing my life, shaping my attention, shaping how I felt when I ate. I started getting more anxious, you know, oh God am I going to feel less full when I eat and so forth. On the protective side it was also confirming I would go out and exercise and say oh yeah this makes sense, I'm feeling good, right?
我可能不会觉得那么饱。然后我会注意到自己没有觉得那么饱，对吧？所以你可以开始看到，我注意到自己，这些信息是如何影响我的生活、塑造我的注意力、塑造我进食时的感受的。我开始变得更加焦虑，哦天哪，我吃饭时会不会觉得不那么饱，诸如此类。在保护性那一面，它也得到了证实，我会出去锻炼并说，哦是的，这说得通，我感觉很好，对吧？
How could she tell if the way she was feeling was because of her genes or because of her mindsets? The only way to answer that question was to run an experiment. So to test this in this study, we recruited participants to a study at Stanford, which they were told they were going to learn their genetic profiles and specifically learn information that would tell them
她怎么能分辨出她当时的感受是因为她的基因还是因为她的思维模式呢？回答这个问题的唯一方法就是进行一项实验。为了在这项研究中对此进行测试，我们在斯坦福大学招募了参与者参加一项研究，他们被告知他们将了解自己的基因特征，特别是了解能够告诉他们
what kind of exercise and diet routines would be most useful. And we had no problem recruiting for this study, at least in the Bay Area here. People were just jumping at the chance to get this personalized information to help them know whether they should have low carb or high carb or, you know, aerobic or anaerobic exercise. So that was interesting first. People were really excited to get this information. And then what we did was we brought them into our lab and we had them run a treadmill task. So this was a very controlled treadmill task where they're on a treadmill. They run at a comfortable pace.
什么样的运动和饮食习惯最有用处的信息。我们在招募这项研究时没有任何问题，至少在湾区的这里是这样。人们简直是抓住机会获得这些个性化的信息，以帮助他们了解自己应该吃低碳水化合物还是高碳水化合物，或者进行有氧还是无氧运动。所以这首先很有趣。人们真的很兴奋能得到这些信息。然后我们做的是把他们带进实验室，让他们在跑步机上跑步。所以这是一个非常受控的跑步机任务，他们在跑步机上跑步。他们以舒适的步伐奔跑。
And then we gradually increase the treadmill each minute, up to a point where they cannot run anymore because it's too hard. And during that, we're measuring their physiological measures of their cardiovascular capacity. So we're looking at their metabolic exchange rate. So that's essentially how quickly they're able to convert oxygen to carbon dioxide. And we're also looking at their ventilation capacity. So how much air can they pump through their lungs per minute?
然后我们每分钟逐渐调高跑步机坡度，直到他们因为太难而跑不动为止。在此期间，我们正在测量他们心血管能力的心血管生理指标。所以我们正在观察他们的代谢交换率。这本质上是他们将氧气转化为二氧化碳的速度。我们还在观察他们的通气能力。也就是他们每分钟可以通过肺部泵送多少空气。
And then they came back one week later. And they were asked to run the same exact task. So we knew what their rate was, we knew what their incline was, and we had them run it again. Only this time, before they got on the treadmill, we said, we have some interesting information from your genetic profile. We had taken samples earlier and had actually figured out what their genes were. And so we had their actual genetic risk profile, and then we told them what it was. But the catch was, we didn't exactly do this, honestly, for everyone.
然后他们在一周后回来了。他们被要求完成完全相同的任务。所以我们知道他们的速率是多少，我们知道他们的坡度是多少，我们让他们再次跑步。只是这一次，在他们踏上跑步机之前，我们说，我们从你的基因特征中获得了一些有趣的信息。我们之前提取了样本，并实际弄清楚了他们的基因是什么。所以我们有他们实际的基因风险特征，然后我们告诉了他们这是什么。但问题是，我们并没有对每个人都完全诚实地这样做。
To put it more bluntly, Alia and her colleagues lied to some of the volunteers. Some of the people who had the protective version of the exercise related gene were told they had the risky version of that gene. Some were told the truth. So you have the other people who are protected, half are told they're protected and half they're told that they're at risk, and of the people who are at risk, half they're told they're at risk and half they're that they're at risk, and of the people who are at risk, half they're told they're at risk, and half they're told they're protected. If genes were primarily responsible for how much people were able to tolerate difficult exercise, the lie should have had no effect.
更直白地说，阿莉亚和她的同事对一些志愿者撒了谎。一些拥有与运动相关的基因保护性版本的人被告知他们拥有该基因的风险版本。一些人被告知了真相。所以你有其他人受到保护，一半人被告知他们受到保护，一半人被告知他们处于风险之中，而在处于风险中的人当中，一半人被告知他们处于风险之中，而另一半人被告知他们处于风险之中，而在处于风险中的人当中，一半人被告知他们处于风险之中，而另一半人被告知他们受到保护。如果基因主要负责人们能够忍受困难运动的程度，那么这个谎言应该没有任何影响。
People with the risky version of the exercise related gene should have been able to tolerate less trenois workouts. On the other hand, if mindsets were responsible for outcomes, you would expect that the lie would make a big difference. People with a form or the gene that predisposed them to inactivity, but who thought they had the gene that allowed them to work out hard would score well on the treadmill task. By this point, you're not going to be surprised at what Alia found. What we found was that that information changed their physiology on the same exact treadmill task in ways that conferred the risk information that was given to them.
拥有与运动相关基因风险版本的人应该只能忍受较少剧烈的锻炼。另一方面，如果思维模式对结果负责，你会期望谎言会产生很大的影响。拥有促使他们不活动但认为自己拥有能够努力锻炼基因的人在跑步机任务上会得分很好。到了这个时候，对于阿莉亚所发现的结果，你不会感到惊讶。我们发现，这些信息在完全相同的跑步机任务中改变了他们的生理机能，其改变方式赋予了他们被告知的风险信息。
So people who were told they were at risk, regardless of whether or not they were at risk, actually reduced the rate at which they were able to convert oxygen into carbon dioxide, and reduced the amount of air they were able to produce through their lungs. In fact, well, that was a reduction of two liters per minute, which is a significant amount, compared to their own baseline levels.
因此，被告知自己处于风险中的人，无论他们是否真的处于风险中，实际上都降低了他们将氧气转化为二氧化碳的速率，并减少了他们通过肺部产生的空气量。事实上，好吧，这比他们自己的基线水平减少了每分钟两升，这是一个相当大的量。
So the same people doing the same task, simply based on what they were told, changed how they responded, physiologically, in this case. I need to stop here to underline this. It wasn't just that people who thought they had bad genes, started exercising less hard. They were able to exercise less hard, then they themselves had done one week earlier. The genetic information had not provided them with insight that liberated them. It had put them in a box. Their lungs performed less well because their mindsets had changed for the worse.
所以同样的人做同样的任务，仅仅根据他们被告知的内容，就改变了他们生理上的反应，在这种情况下。我需要在这里停下来强调这一点。不仅仅是那些认为自己基因不好的人开始减少锻炼强度。他们能够进行的锻炼强度比他们自己一周前做的还要低。基因信息并没有为他们提供解放他们的洞察力。它把他们关进了一个盒子里。他们的肺部表现变差了，因为他们的思维模式变坏了。
The exact same thing happened when Aliyah told volunteers about a gene that predisposed people to overeating. So we ran a similar designed study, but with the FTO gene. And this pair, in this paradigm, they came to the lab, they did the genetic test, then they drank a milkshake. They were more lucky to be in the milkshake study than the exercise study. They drank a milkshake and we measured blood samples of a peptide that's related to satiety.
当阿莉亚向志愿者讲述一个使人们容易暴饮暴食的基因时，发生了完全相同的事情。所以我们进行了一项设计类似的研究，但针对的是FTO基因。在这个范例中，他们来到实验室，进行了基因测试，然后他们喝了一杯奶昔。他们比参加运动研究的人更有可能参与奶昔研究。他们喝了一杯奶昔，我们测量了与饱腹感相关的某种肽的血液样本。
And we measured them at baseline, and then they came back a one week later, did the same drink, the same exact milkshake, and here again, immediately before drinking that milkshake, we gave them their information about the FTO gene and the risk that that conferred. And what did you find? Yeah, and here again, we found that
我们在基线时对他们进行了测量，然后他们在一周后回来，喝了相同的饮料，完全相同的奶昔，在这里同样，在喝那杯奶昔之前，我们给了他们关于FTO基因的信息以及它所带来的风险。你发现了什么？是的，在这里我们再次发现，
learning their genetic risk changed their blood levels, like their gut peptide levels of the satiety inducing hormone in ways that conferred that risk. Millions of Americans, as I said, have taken genetic tests. In cases where those tests have allowed them to take protective measures against various medical ailments, that's obviously a good thing. But lots of people have also received bad news
了解他们的基因风险改变了他们的血液水平，比如诱导饱腹感的激素的肠道肽水平，其改变方式赋予了这种风险。正如我所说，数百万美国人已经进行了基因检测。在这些测试允许他们针对各种疾病采取保护措施的情况下，这显然是一件好事。但很多人也收到了坏消息
about various genes, bad news that they can do nothing about. What are the risks? This information has reshaped their mindsets and their bodies for the worse. In another study, Alia has found that if there are some people heard by believing they are not cut out for exercise, others, like Alia herself in college, are affected by the belief that they are not getting enough exercise, even when they are. Yeah, the idea for this study actually came from Professor Ellen Langer, who was a
关于各种基因的坏消息，他们对此无能为力。风险是什么？这些信息重塑了他们的思维模式和身体，朝着不好的方向发展。在另一项研究中，阿莉亚发现，如果有些人因为觉得自己不适合运动而受到伤害，那么其他人，比如大学时的阿莉亚本人，则受到以下信念的影响：他们觉得自己运动量不够，即使他们实际上运动量足够。是的，这项研究的想法实际上来自埃伦·兰格教授，她是我在哈佛读本科时的
mentor of mine as an undergrad at Harvard. And this was when I was playing hockey, and as we talked about having that feeling of never getting enough exercise. And I remember going to a lab meeting one day with Ellen, and I sort of told her that I was on the hockey team, and then I had just come from a workout or something, and she was like, oh, exercise. You know, that's just a placebo effect, right? And Ellen was like this. She's one of these people who's very provocative,
导师。当时我正在打曲棍球，正如我们所谈到的那种从未获得足够运动的感觉。我记得有一天去参加埃伦的实验室会议，我向她提起我是曲棍球队的，我当时刚锻炼完之类的，然后她就说，哦，运动。你知道，那只是一种安慰剂效应，对吧？埃伦就是这样的人。她是那种非常具有挑衅性的人，
but also very wise. And I remember that phrase, that saying just sort of like, shocking me, I was like, wait, what? Like exercise is not a placebo. This is very serious, you know, what you're doing and how much you're doing, it matters, right? And that was like, well, wait a second. You know, we've learned, we know very well
但也非常有智慧。我记得那个词组，那种说法简直让我感到震惊，我在想，等等，什么？就像运动不是安慰剂一样。这非常严重，你知道，你在做什么以及你做了多少，这很重要，对吧？那就变成了，好吧，等一下。你知道，我们已经了解到，我们非常清楚
that the effects of drugs are in part driven by placebos, by the belief in them. And we've shifted as a society towards relying on behavioral medicine, exercise, diet, reducing stress to improve our health. Why wouldn't it be the case that the placebo-like effect, the placebo effect, if you will, or the belief effect, why wouldn't it play a role too in determining the benefit of health behaviors like exercise, diet, and stress? So when I started to think about it, I realized this wasn't such an outrageous thing to say,
药物的效果部分是由安慰剂、由对它们的信仰驱动的。我们作为一个社会已经转向依赖行为医学——运动、饮食、减压来改善我们的健康。为什么类似安慰剂的效果，如果你愿意的话，安慰剂效应，或者说信念效应，为什么它在决定健康行为（如运动、饮食和减压）的好处时，不也发挥作用呢？所以当我开始思考这个问题时，我意识到这并不是什么离谱的说法，
but nobody had looked into that. And the reason was, we don't have placebo exercise, right? It's not as easy as giving somebody a sugar pill with the belief that it's a real medication. So we had to design a study that essentially mirrored the concept of doing the exact same thing, but just changing your belief about it. And what we came up with was to work with a group of women who were cleaning hotel rooms. So these were housekeepers and they were getting an extraordinary amount of physical activity every day in their jobs. They were on their feet all day long, pushing carts, changing linens, vacuuming, you name it. It's tough to quantify the exact amount but it was clear that they were getting above and beyond the surgeon general's requirements, which were at
但没有人去研究过。原因在于，我们没有安慰剂运动，对吧？这不像给某人一颗糖丸并让他相信它是真正的药物那么容易。所以我们必须设计一项研究，它本质上反映了做完全相同的事情但只改变你对它的信念的概念。我们想出的办法是与一群打扫酒店房间的女性合作。这些是客房服务员，她们在工作中每天都有大量的体力活动。她们整天站着，推车子，换床单，吸尘，应有尽有。很难精确量化具体的工作量，但很明显她们的运动量已经远远超出了卫生局长的要求，当时的要求是
the time to accumulate 30 minutes of moderate physical activity per day. So it's clear that they were getting the exercise they needed to be healthy, to have a healthy way, to healthy heart, healthy mental health, and so forth. But what was interesting about these women is that they were not aware of it. So when we asked them, we said, hey, how much, you know, do you get regular exercise? Yes or no.
每天积累30分钟的中等强度体力活动。所以很明显，她们得到了保持健康所需的运动，拥有健康的体重、健康的心脏、健康的心理健康等等。但这些女性有趣的地方在于她们并没有意识到这一点。所以当我们问她们时，我们说，嘿，你有多少，你知道的，你经常锻炼吗？有还是没有。
And two thirds of them said no. And then we asked them, how much exercise do you get on a scale of zero to 10? And the third of them said zero. They said, nothing, I get no exercise at all. Because they were thinking of getting exercises, actually going to a gym or running on a treadmill as opposed to the work they were doing every day.
其中三分之二的人说没有。然后我们问她们，在零到十的量表上，你得到了多少运动量？其中三分之一的人说零。她们说，什么都没有，我一点运动都没有。因为她们认为的锻炼实际上是去健身房或在跑步机上跑步，而不是她们每天在做的工作。
Exactly. They had in their heads the mindset that exercises, the Zoombook class or the spin class or running that it wasn't their work. And they would go home at the end of the day, exhausted, tired work and they would go home at the end of the day, exhausted and tired and sore. But they had the mindset that their work was just that, hard, thankless, tiresome work.
完全正确。她们脑子里有一种思维模式，认为锻炼是尊巴舞课、动感单车课或跑步，而不是她们的工作。她们一天结束时会回家，精疲力竭，疲惫不堪地工作，她们一天结束时会回家，精疲力竭，疲惫不堪，肌肉酸痛。但她们的思维模式是，她们的工作就是那样——艰辛、吃力不讨好、令人厌烦的工作。
And so what we wanted to see was what would happen if we could change that, if we could instill in them, the mindset that their work was good exercise. And it was so easy to do. That was what was so neat about the study was I got to go into these hotels. We worked with seven hotels, some in the Boston area and some in Colorado, and I went in and all I did was say, hey, the work you are doing is good exercise. It meets the surgeon general's requirements and as a result you should be receiving these benefits a healthy heart, a healthy weight, and so forth.
所以我们想要看看，如果我们能改变这一点会发生什么，如果我们能在她们心中灌输这样一种思维模式：她们的工作就是很好的运动。这做起来太容易了。这正是这项研究所巧妙的地方，我可以走进这些酒店。我们与七家酒店合作，其中一些在波士顿地区，一些在科罗拉多州，我走进去，我所做的就是说，嘿，你们正在做的工作是很好的运动。它符合卫生局长的要求，因此你们应该获得这些好处——健康的心脏、健康的体重等等。
Now we gave this information but we did it in a strategic way. We did it in a randomized control trial in which we randomized only half of them to receive that at one time. So we were able to compare the group of women who received that information versus the group of women who didn't receive it yet. We gave it to them after the end of the study. And what we found was that simply informing them that their work was good exercise
现在我们提供了这些信息，但我们是以一种有策略的方式做到的。我们进行了一项随机对照试验，其中我们仅将其中一半人随机分配到当时就接收到该信息的组别中。因此，我们能够比较接受该信息的女性群体与尚未接受该信息的女性群体。我们在研究结束后将信息提供给了她们。我们发现，仅仅告知她们她们的工作是很好的运动
led to changes in their health. They had a reduction in weight. They showed a reduction in systolic blood pressure. We found, we didn't report it in the paper, but we also showed improvements in their mental health, better body image, better self-esteem, and so forth. And it makes sense, right? You can think about if your whole life is defined in one way.
就带来了她们健康的改变。她们的体重有所减轻。她们表现出收缩压的降低。我们发现，虽然我们在论文中没有报告这一点，但我们也展示了她们心理健康的改善，更好的身体形象，更好的自尊等等。这很合理，对吧？你可以想象，如果你的整个生活都以某种方式被定义。
And then you learned that you can view it in a wholly different way. And that way makes you feel better about yourself. You can see how the whole game would really change for them. It's really profound, though. I mean, the idea that these women were doing the same work, or if you will, doing the same exercise before and after, and just thinking about what they were doing differently, transforms biological markers of their health. I mean, it's actually quite
然后你了解到你可以用一种完全不同的方式来看待它。那种方式让你对自己感觉更好。你可以看到整场比赛对她们来说真的会发生改变。不过，这真的很深奥。我的意思是，这些女性在前后做着相同的工作，或者如果你愿意的话，做着相同的运动，仅仅通过思考她们在做什么不同，就改变了她们健康的生物学标志物。我的意思是，这实际上相当
astonishing. Yeah, it was astonishing to me at the time. The more research I've done in this area, you come to realize that we really shouldn't be astonished by this. For reasons you've pointed out and that we've discussed, it's like our brain's whole job is to prepare, prioritize, and regulate the internal body based on what it believes to be true about the external environment. So if you change that, it just changes how our body is being regulated.
令人惊讶。是的，当时这让我感到惊讶。我在这个领域做的研究越多，你就会意识到我们其实不应该对此感到惊讶。出于你已经指出并讨论过的原因，这就像我们大脑的全部工作是根据它认为关于外部环境的真实情况，来准备、优先处理和调节内部身体。所以如果你改变了这一点，它就会改变我们身体被调节的方式。
I think we need to move, I've moved, and I think it would benefit our society as a whole to move from being less wowed by this research. Okay, this is something to be expected. Our brain is an organ in the body. And you change that, you change our mental framework. We should expect that it will change our physiology. Well, I want to talk about one other study of yours that I think did have a big wow factor when it first came out. And that was your milkshake study. Tell me about that study earlier. Yeah, so in this study, we gave people the same exact milkshake
我认为我们需要转变，我已经转变了，我认为这有利于我们整个社会从对这项研究感到惊叹转向不再那么惊讶。好吧，这是意料之中的事情。我们的大脑是身体里的一个器官。你改变了它，你就改变了我们的心理框架。我们应该期望它会改变我们的生理机能。好吧，我想谈谈你的另一项研究，我认为它在刚问世时确实具有很大的惊艳因素。那是你的奶昔研究。能跟我讲讲那项早期研究吗？是的，在这项研究中，我们在
at two different time points. It was about a 350 calorie modest amount of sugar milkshake. But at one time point, we told people it was an indulgent shake, 620 calories, high fat, high calorie, high sugar. And at the other time point we told them it was 140 calories, light and fit diet shake. We called it the the sense of shake. And what we found was that even though they were drinking the same exact milkshake at both time points, their bodies responded differently. We were measuring their peptide levels. In this case, we're looking at grellin, which is a hunger and metabolism regulating hormone. And what we found was that when they thought they
两个不同的时间点给人们提供了完全相同的奶昔。那是一杯大约350卡路里、含糖量适中的奶昔。但在一个时间点上，我们告诉人们它是一杯让人纵情享受的奶昔，有620卡路里，高脂肪、高卡路里、高糖。而在另一个时间点，我们告诉人们它是140卡路里的清淡健康减肥奶昔。我们称它为感知奶昔。我们发现，尽管他们在两个时间点喝的是完全相同的奶昔，但他们的身体反应却有所不同。我们正在测量他们的肽水平。在这种情况下，我们着眼于胃饥饿素，这是一种调节饥饿感和新陈代谢的激素。我们发现，当他们认为自己
were eating an indulgent milkshake, their grellin levels dropped at a three-fold rate compared to when they thought they were consuming the sensible shake. Their grellen levels dropped at a threefold rate compared to when they thought they were consuming the sensible shake. In other words, when they thought they were having the indulgent milkshake, they felt fuller compared to when they thought they were having the healthy milkshake. Yeah, physiologically, they felt more satiated. What do you think the study is telling us, Alia? On the one hand, I do think it's astonishing. I think people would be surprised to learn that the very same milkshake can have different effects on your hormones depending on how you think about them. But I'm wondering what you make of this and also what you make of this in the light of your
喝着令人纵情享受奶昔的人，其饥饿素水平下降的速度是自认为在喝健康奶昔的人的三倍。他们体内饥饿素水平下降的速度是自以为在喝健康奶昔的人的三倍。换句话说，当他们觉得自己喝的是那杯让人大快朵颐的奶昔时，相比于觉得自己喝的是健康奶昔的时候，他们会感到更饱。是的，在生理上，他们感到更有饱腹感。你认为这项研究说明了什么，阿莉娅？一方面，我确实觉得这很令人惊奇。我想人们会惊讶地发现，完全相同的奶昔对你的荷尔蒙会产生不同的影响，这取决于你是如何看待它们的。但我在想，你是如何看待这一点的，以及鉴于你
own concerns about your own food consumption and how you thought about food. Yeah, so the first thing to realize in this study is that our body's response to food is not merely the product of the actual objective qualities of the nutrients. It's also a product of what we believe and expect about those nutrients. So the fact that it's a combination of those things, the objective reality of what we're eating and our beliefs about what we're eating, that alone is groundbreaking. It's like, wow, you know, oh, we haven't been thinking about that. We spend so much time talking about calories in, calories out or high carb, low carb, keto, non-keto, whatever the, you know,
对自身食物摄入的担忧以及你对食物的看法，你又如何看待这一点。是的，所以这项研究首先要意识到的是，我们身体对食物的反应不仅仅是营养物质实际客观属性的产物。它也是我们对这些营养物质的信念和期望的产物。因此，它是这些因素结合的产物——我们所吃东西的客观现实以及我们对所吃东西的信念，仅这一点就是突破性的。这就像是，哇，你知道的，哦，我们以前没有考虑过这一点。我们花了大把的时间讨论摄入的热量与消耗的热量，或者高碳水、低碳水、生酮、非生酮，不管是什么，你知道的，
fat diet of the month is, it's all about the objective qualities of the food. And we've done almost nothing to think about the role our beliefs and mindsets and experience might play in shaping our body's response to that food. So that's one thing. But the second thing we learned in this study was actually most profound for me at least. And that is that the manner in which our mindsets mattered was actually the exact opposite of how I thought it would play out. So I went into this study thinking, OK, I bet
每月的潮流减肥法是什么，这些全都是关于食物的客观属性。而我们几乎没有做任何事情去思考我们的信念、心态和经验在塑造我们身体对食物的反应方面可能扮演的角色。所以这是一回事。但我们在研究中学到的第二件事，对我来说至少是最深远的。那就是我们的心态发挥作用的方式，实际上与我原以为的发展方式完全相反。所以我进入这项研究时想的是，好吧，我打赌
we're going to see some physiological effect because I'd seen it before with placebo effects and with the exercise, rheumatoid and study and so forth. So I thought we might get something, but I just assumed that the better mindset to be in was the mindset that you were eating sensibly, that you were eating a health shake. I thought, okay, that that will confer healthier outcomes. And what we found was that it was the exact opposite. So assuming you want to maintain or lose weight,
我们会看到一些生理效应，因为我在安慰剂效应、运动、类风湿研究等方面以前见过它。所以我认为我们可能会得到一些结果，但我只是假设，保持更好的心态应该是那种你吃得很合理、你吃的是健康奶昔的心态。我想，好的，这会带来更健康的成果。而我们发现的情况却恰恰相反。因此，假设你想保持或减轻体重，
you would want to actually have your grill and levels drop at a greater rate after you eat food. Why? Because that will make you feel more physiologically satiated, and it will also raise metabolism to burn the nutrients that were just ingested. And what we found was that when people thought they were eating healthy, in this case, it conveyed a sense of sensibility, or in fact, a lack of calories, a sense of not enough. That sens signals to the body that they weren't getting enough, so they felt less physiologically
你实际上会希望在你吃完食物后，你的饥饿素水平以更快的速度下降。为什么？因为这会让你在生理上感觉更饱，它还会提高新陈代谢来燃烧刚刚摄入的营养成分。而我们发现的是，当人们认为自己吃得很健康时，在这种情况下，它传达了一种合理的感觉，或者实际上，是一种热量不足的感觉，一种“不够”的感觉。这种感觉向身体发出信号，表明他们摄入不足，因此他们在生理上感觉没那么
satiated, and we don't know because we didn't test people over a long period of time, but that could have influenced metabolism in ways that slowed metabolism, led to weight gain versus weight loss. So that was a huge aha for me. ... Yeah, and in some ways this is so diametrically opposed to the way we talk about food in general, right? We talk about healthy food as being virtuous,
饱，而且我们不知道，因为我们没有对人们进行长期追踪测试，但这可能会以减慢新陈代谢的方式影响新陈代谢，导致体重增加而不是减轻。所以这对我是个巨大的顿悟。……是的，在某些方面，这与我们通常谈论食物的方式截然相反，对吧？我们把健康食物说成是高尚的、
as being sensible, as being, yeah, not very tasty, but really, really good for you. And we talk about unhealthy food as being, wow, really sinfully delicious, and so amazing, and so so rich and tasty. And in some ways, we're talking about things backward. That's exactly right. And then once you see it, you see it everywhere. Every time you say it's healthy, at least in an art culture in the US and gradually across the whole world, the assumption is that it's not filling, not indulgent, not tasty, and kind of in some cases, disgusting and depriving.
合理的，是的，不是很好吃，但对你真的真的很有益。而我们将不健康的食物描述为，哇，极度诱人、美味无比，而且如此浓郁可口。在某种程度上，我们的说法完全倒置了。完全正确。一旦你注意到了这一点，你就会发现它无处不在。每当你说它是健康的，至少在我们的美国文化中，并逐渐在全世界范围内，人们的假设就是它不顶饱、不能让人纵情享受、不好吃，而且在某些情况下，让人觉得恶心和剥夺。
And those beliefs, those associations with healthy food don't just lead to us not wanting to eat those things, changing our behavior. But what we showed in the study is that they might also be influencing our physiology in ways that keep us from getting the benefits of eating healthy foods. When we come back, applying the signs of mindsets in our own lives. The words like succulent, mouthwatering, creamy, dirty, naked, still binding, right? Those don't describe the dish, they're just flair.
而这些信念，这些与健康食物的联系，不仅导致我们不想吃这些东西、改变我们的行为。但我们在研究中展示的是，它们还可能以某种方式影响我们的生理机能，使我们无法获得吃健康食品的好处。当我们回来时，将心态的科学应用到我们自己的生活中。诸如汁水丰盈、令人垂涎、奶油般细腻、肮脏、赤裸、引人入胜之类的词，对吧？那些并不是在描述这道菜，它们只是修饰。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Some weeks ago, I found myself at a Mexican restaurant. I was looking through the cocktails and came by a margarita called la piñata. A piñata, of course, is a decorated toy hung from a ceiling that kids break open by whacking with a stick. Sounds good, I thought, and ordered the drink. When I glanced over to the healthy side of the menu, nothing was called lapindyata.
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。几周前，我发现自己置身于一家墨西哥餐厅。我翻看鸡尾酒单时，看到了一款名为“皮纳塔（la piñata）”的玛格丽特酒。皮纳塔当然是一个挂在天花板上的装饰玩具，孩子们用棍子把它敲碎。听起来不错，我想着，便点了这杯酒。当我扫视菜单健康的那一端时，没有任何东西被称为“皮纳塔”。
There were sober salads, gentle greens, and virtuous vegetables. I thought back to that menu after I talked with Stanford psychologist Alia Kram. Why do unhealthy foods get the cool names? Why do healthy foods get more in names? We ran a linguistic study with Dandaravsky, who's a linguist here at Stanford, where we analyzed the language used to describe items on chain restaurants in America,
那里有清淡的沙拉、温和的蔬菜和高尚的蔬菜。在与斯坦福大学心理学家阿莉娅·克拉姆交谈后，我想起了那份菜单。为什么不健康的食物能得到酷炫的名字？为什么健康的食物得到的名字更……？我们和斯坦福大学的语言学家达恩·达拉夫斯基（Dandaravsky）一起做了一项语言学研究，我们分析了美国连锁餐厅中用来描述菜品的语言，
like chilies and apple bees and outback steakhouse. And we looked at the language used to describe items on the regular menu, and compared looked at the language used to describe items on the regular menu, and compared that to the language used to describe the items on the designated healthy menu. You know, it's either its own page or marked by a little green leaf or something.
比如辣椒餐厅（Chili's）、阿普比（Applebee's）和牛排屋（Outback Steakhouse）。我们查看了用于描述常规菜单上菜品的语言，并进行了比较——查看了用于描述常规菜单上菜品的语言，并将其与用于标明健康菜单上菜品的语言进行了比较。你知道，它要么是单独的一页，要么标有一片小绿叶什么的。
And essentially, what we found there is that the language, the words used to describe the healthy foods was far less appealing than the words used to describe the normal dishes. So it was far less exciting, words like crazy or spellbinding, far less sort of provocative words like dangerous, dirty or naked, far less indulgent words like bliss, succulent, mouthwatering. And this was really interesting because we weren't maybe not surprised by that. We're like, okay, how are healthy foods described? Well, they're used with very nutritious words like
从本质上讲，我们在那里发现的是，用来描述健康食物的语言、词汇，远不如用来描述普通菜肴的词汇那么有吸引力。所以它的兴奋感要少得多，比如“疯狂”或“迷人”这样的词，缺乏诸如“危险的”、“肮脏的”或“赤裸的”这样有点挑衅性的词，也缺乏诸如“极乐”、“汁水丰盈”、“令人垂涎”这样让人纵情享受的词。这真的很有趣，因为我们可能对此并不感到惊讶。我们会想，好吧，健康食物是如何被描述的？嗯，它们使用的是非常营养的词汇，比如
wholesome, our nutritional, or perhaps fresh words like fresh or freshly, but they're not often described with these exciting descriptors. So that was not all that surprising. What was interesting is that when we looked at these words, almost none of them said anything about the dish itself, right? So it wasn't like the indulgent words had to be reserved for the hamburger and not for the low fat trout dish. Right, right. The words like succulent, mouthwatering, creamy, dirty, naked, still binding, right?
有益健康的、营养的，或者是新鲜的词汇，比如新鲜的或刚出炉的，但它们不经常用这些令人兴奋的修饰语来描述。所以这并不是那么令人惊奇。有趣的是，当我们审视这些词汇时，几乎没有一个词提到了这道菜本身，对吧？因此，这并不是说那些纵情享受的词必须留给汉堡包，而不能留给低脂虹鳟鱼菜肴。对，对的。诸如汁水丰盈、令人垂涎、奶油般细腻、肮脏、赤裸、引人入胜之类的词，对吧？
Those don't describe the dish, they just flare. So what would happen? Could we actually use those same words to describe healthy foods? And so we did this at Stanford, and we later replicated it at several different universities around the US. We took the vegetable dish that they were serving to their students, and we had them prepare it the same exact way.
那些并不是在描述这道菜，它们只是修饰。那么会发生什么呢？我们实际上可以用这些相同的词来描述健康的食物吗？所以我们在斯坦福大学做了这个实验，后来我们在美国各地的几所不同大学进行了重复实验。我们拿出了他们提供给学生的蔬菜菜肴，让他们用完全相同的方式烹饪。
This was over the course of 10 week quarter. We had them prepare it the same exact way. But we randomized how it was labeled. So sometimes it was labeled just very basic, so it would be carrots or beets. Sometimes it was labeled healthy, so lighter choice beets with no added sugar. And sometimes it was labeled in the indulgent way,
这是一个持续10周的学期。我们让他们用完全相同的方式烹饪。但我们将其贴标签的方式随机化了。所以有时它的标签非常基础，比如胡萝卜或甜菜。有时它的标签是健康的，比如加了“无添加糖的轻食选择甜菜”。有时它的标签是让人纵情享受的，
so dynamite chili lime season beets or zesty twisted citrus carrots, something like that. We just use the same words that are used on these chain restaurants out in America selling less healthy items. And what we found was that when the vegetables were labeled and with indulgent descriptors, people chose them and consumed them at a far greater
比如“劲爆辣椒青柠风味甜菜”或“浓郁风味柑橘胡萝卜”，诸如此类。我们只是用了美国那些售卖不太健康食品的连锁餐厅所使用的相同词汇。我们发现，当蔬菜被贴上带有纵情享受色彩的描述性标签时，人们选择和消耗它们的比例要高得多。
rate. The studies differed, but the average was about a 30% increase in vegetable consumption. Wow. In some ways this speaks to your own challenges in thinking about food, going back to your college days, Alia, where you were asking yourself, have I eating too much or am I eating right in terms of my athletic endeavors? And in some ways, this turns things on its head, does it not, in terms of how we should think about food and our diet choices. I had a really unhealthy relationship with food
这些研究结果有所不同，但平均而言，蔬菜消费量大约增加了30%。哇。在某些方面，这反映了你自己在思考食物时所面临的挑战，回到你的大学时代，阿莉娅，当时你在问自己，我是不是吃得太多了，或者就我的运动努力而言，我吃得对不对。在某些方面，这彻底颠覆了现状，不是吗？关于我们应该如何看待食物和饮食选择。我曾与食物建立过一种非常不健康的关系，
when I was in college and it was characterized by this constant feeling like I should eat the healthy foods but it's not what I really wanted to eat and so I would go through these patterns of eating healthy eating healthy and then kind of like breaking that and having overeating and I actually went through a short period of bulimia because of that approach. And this insight, this aha changed me forever. It changed me in a sustained way. I'm changed to this day. And it was this changed to this day and it was this
当我在上大学的时候，它的特点是这种挥之不去的感觉：我觉得我应该吃健康的食物，但这并不是我真正想吃的，所以我经历了这样的循环：吃健康的食物，吃健康的食物，然后有点像打破戒律，暴饮暴食，由于这种方法，我其实经历了一小段贪食症时期。这种洞察力，这个顿悟永远地改变了我。它以一种持久的方式改变了我。直到今天我都在改变。这就是——直到今天我都在改变，这就是——
realization a that the mindset that I'm in has an impact so if I'm feeling like I'm not getting enough or that I'm restricting my food That mindset alone might be working against me might be counteracting my hard efforts at Dieting or eating healthy and then the other thing it made me realize was What's the goal of eating the goal of eating is to feel like you're eating enough, to feel like you're eating indulgently that you're feeling satisfied, that you're feeling good with what you eat. So that became the goal for me. And it didn't mean I just threw all caution to the wind and ate, you know, only milkshakes and fries.
这种认识：a，我所处的心态会产生影响，所以如果我觉得我没有摄入足够的东西，或者我在限制我的食物，这种心态本身可能就在与我作对，可能会抵制我在节食或健康饮食方面付出的艰苦努力；然后另一件事让我意识到的是，进食的目标是什么？进食的目标是感觉你吃得够多了，感觉你吃得很纵情，感觉你得到了满足，感觉你对你吃的东西感到满意。所以这成了我的目标。这并不意味着我把一切警惕抛诸脑后，只吃奶昔和炸薯条。
In fact, I found that I didn't actually crave those things when I wasn't trying to avoid them. If I went about life with the goal of, what can I eat that will actually make me feel satisfied, feel that sense of enough? And that was the goal. I would choose things naturally that were healthier, right? And not all the time, sometimes I would choose a hamburger, but that's what felt right for me. And it was freeing and it was profound. It really truly was the study that changed me most on my journey. When I think about the public health messages we often have around food and exercise,
事实上，我发现当我并不试图去回避它们时，我其实并不渴望那些东西。如果我带着这样的目标度过生活：我能吃什么才能真正让我感到满足，感受到那种“足够”的感觉？这就是目标。我会自然而然地选择更健康的食物，对吧？并非总是如此，有时我会选择一个汉堡包，但那是我觉得对的东西。这是一种解放，而且意义深远。这确实是那项在我的人生旅程中改变我最多的研究。当我想到我们围绕食物和运动经常听到的公共健康信息时，
so many of the healthful messages have a punitive edge to them. We tell people there's an obesity epidemic in America or around the world. We need to eat healthier. Bad things are going to happen to you if you don't eat healthier. Social media is full of examples of healthy people working out and running 20 miles every day. We make comparisons to those people. In some ways, I'm not sure all of this really squares with your work on mindsets in terms
许多健康信息都带有惩罚性的色彩。我们告诉人们，美国或世界各地存在着肥胖流行病。我们需要吃得更健康。如果你不吃得更健康，就会有坏事发生在你身上。社交媒体上到处都是健康的人锻炼身体、每天跑步20英里的例子。我们将自己与那些人进行比较。在某些方面，我并不确定所有这一切真的符合你关于心态的研究，
of what's actually going to move the needle for ordinary people who might not have time to work out three hours every day. Yeah, so we know that food, eating healthy and getting good amount of exercise is good for us, but all these messages telling people what to do often just make people feel badly about what they're doing. And what we've learned is psychologists is that feeling like you're not getting enough does not motivate you, most people at least,
就什么才能真正为普通人带来改变而言，他们可能没有时间每天锻炼三个小时。是的，所以我们知道食物、健康饮食和适量运动对我们有益，但所有这些告诉人们该怎么做的信息，往往只会让人对自己的所作所为感到糟糕。而我们作为心理学家所了解到的是，觉得你没有得到足够的东西并不能激励你——至少对大多数人来说——
to get more, right? In some cases, it often leads to giving up or letting go or deciding you really don't care about being healthy. So we need to find that line between informing people about the value of these behaviors, but also instilling mindsets that actually make people feel like they identify with those behaviors and like they want to do those behaviors. How can we make healthy
去得到更多，对吧？在某些情况下，它往往会导致放弃、放任自流，或者决定你根本不在乎是否健康。所以我们需要找到这样一条界限：既要让人们了解这些行为的价值，又要灌输这样一种心态，即真正让人们觉得他们认同这些行为，并且他们想要做出这些行为。我们如何才能让健康
eating pleasurable, indulgent? How can we make exercise feel inviting and inspiring? Those are the questions. And I think our country, our world, would be better served if we could focus our time, money, effort, and energy on instilling those mindsets rather than reminding people time and time again that they're not enough. Alia is a pain to remind people, especially those who have just heard about the power
饮食变得令人愉悦、纵情享受？我们如何才能让锻炼感觉诱人且鼓舞人心？这些就是问题所在。而且我认为如果我们能将时间、金钱、努力和精力集中在灌输这些心态上，而不是一次又一次地提醒人们他们还不够好，我们的国家、我们的世界将会变得更好。阿莉娅，提醒人们不要把这些见解做得过头，这是一件很痛苦的事，尤其是对那些刚刚听到心态力量的人来说。
of mindsets, not to go overboard with these insights. It's one thing to say, doctors and public health experts should pay attention to mindsets when they communicate health information. It's another thing entirely, to say that mindsets are the only thing that matter. The best mindset to be in when you have cancer is not, I don't have cancer, or cancer is nothing, right? It's, cancer is manageable. That's a different mindset that has more adaptive outcomes,
说医生和公共卫生专家在传达健康信息时应该关注心态是一回事。而说心态是唯一重要的事情则是完全另一回事。当你患癌症时，最好的心态不是“我没有得癌症”或者“癌症不算什么”，对吧？而是“癌症是可控的”。这是一种不同的心态，具有更多适应性的结果，至少这是我们所看到的。你知道的，当谈到健康食品时，这不仅仅是“哦，我在吃健康的食物”，对吧？而是“哦，实际上，那种心态适得其反”。为什么？嗯，回想一下这种心态是如何影响你的生理机能的……嗯，如果你能弄清楚你的注意力、行为、情绪和生理机能，
at least that we've seen. You know, when it comes to healthy food, it's not just, oh, I'm eating healthy, right? It's, oh, actually, that mindset is counterproductive. Why? Well, think back to how that mindset influences your physi... Well, your attention, your behavior, your emotions, and physiology, if you can figure that out.
然后你就会明白哪种心态最有效。因此，心态的影响是非常复杂的，我们对于理解哪些心态重要、为什么重要、它们有多重要以及它们在什么时候不重要，真的还只是冰山一角。再说一次，我认为在我们了解所有这一切之前，一种很好的方法是总是两手抓，对吧？所以如果我生病了，我不仅仅是改变心态。我在适当的时候去看医生，在适当的时候吃药。我做实际的事情来让自己好起来，但我也关注我的心态。让自己好起来，但我也关注我的心态。
And then you'll realize what mindset is most effective. So, the effects of mindset is very sophisticated and we're really just at the tip of the iceberg of understanding which mindset's matter. Why do they matter? How much do they matter? And when do they not matter? And again, I think before we know all of that, a good way to sort of approach this is to always do both, right? So if I get sick, I don't just change my mindset. I go to the doctor where I appropriate, I take medications where appropriate. I do the physical things to make me better, but I also focus on my mindset. better, but I also focus on my mindset.
阿莉娅·克拉姆是斯坦福大学的心理学家。她研究心态塑造我们体验和应对世界的方式的力量。阿莉娅，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，香卡。这真是太愉快了。《隐藏大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷勒、瑞恩·卡茨、
Alia Kram is a psychologist at Stanford University. She studies the power of mindsets to shape the way we experience and respond to the world. Alia, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much, Shankar. It's been such a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz,
奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们无名英雄是广告合作伙伴 Stitcher 传媒的亚历山德拉·格洛纳。她帮助我们追踪播客指标、每周和每月的下载量以及其他形式的互动。这极其重要，因为这是最清晰的方式，
Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero is Alexandra Gloner at our advertising partner, Stitcher Media. She helps us keep track of our podcast metrics, weekly and monthly downloads, and other forms of engagement. This is extremely important because it is the clearest way
让我们能够分辨哪些单集能引起你的共鸣，哪些主题和话题能触动心弦。大家称她为 AJ，她认真负责、乐于助人，她的见解帮助改进了我们的工作。如果你有特别喜欢的《隐藏大脑》单集，AJ 很可能就是那个帮我们构思出这个主题的无名英雄。谢谢你，AJ。
for us to tell what episodes resonate with you, what themes and topics strike a chord. AJ, as she is called, is conscientious and helpful and her insights have helped improve our work. If there are hidden brain episodes you especially love, AJ might well have been the unsung hero who helped us dream up the topic. Thank you AJ.
如果你喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一遍，如果你想支持你喜爱的节目，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
If you like this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you would like to help support the show you love, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这期节目，并希望我们制作更多类似的内容，请考虑支持我们的工作。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次强调，如果你想支持你喜爱的节目，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。